Clutter, clutter everywhere,...
...not a drop of free space anywhere.
Dawn Sandomeno was drowning in her messy home office,...
...so she and her partner were forced to work at the dining room table.
My clutter issue is basically paper,...
...things that I need to file away, and the other thing in the room...
...is I think we're having an issue of whether it's a gym or an office,...
...and really, it's some sort of bedroom.
So, the whole issue is stressing us out.
Good Housekeeping sent in clutter expert Lorie Marrero...
...with an organizing program designed to get Dawn's space in shape,...
...beginning with this vision board purchased from a used furniture store.
This is for you to manage your to-do list and your projects,...
...and we've set it up here with some of your stuff from your business.
This is exactly what I needed,...
...and the fact that I can close it up is even better.
Terrific!
Marrero says, "Keep a to-be-filed box on your desk,...
...and once it fills up, you've got a physical cue to file the material."
I'm Terry Anzur for Good Housekeeping Reports.